Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to take a look at MPCs
and how they work overall and why using them.
And then in the following video,
we'll actually break it down and make one ourselves.
So let's get started.
So first up, many people wonder
what is a material parameter collection?
Well, what they are is they allow us to go in here
and to be able to adjust things sweepingly in a material
to be able to control the properties
and the look and feel.
They can range from anything from making flowers die
to changing the color of them
or to make them look like they're more wet.
I'm going to show you the example that I have,
the MPCs active and a little bit about how they work
in the scene and then in the following video,
we'll actually do it ourselves.
So let's go and jump into Unreal and take a look.
So here in Unreal, we have a scene set up
and this is using the MPC underscore mat.
If you're wondering where that's at,
go into your class files
and you'll see on your class files under maps,
you'll see the MPC mat.
That's the one that I have open here.
We're going to also go ahead and open up our cinematics.
So let's go to contents, open up cinematics folder
and we're going to go ahead
and open up our MPC simple animation.
In here, we can go ahead and hit play
and as we hit play,
we can actually see things change over time.
I'm just simply sliding over the bar
and you can see the materials get wetter
and the rain appear in the opacity here.
Now, this is all being able to be controlled via an MPC.
We can add whatever actors that we need
and then we can also, when we do that,
load a material parameter collection
connected to that actor, as you see in my menu.
The MPCs, if we go to that folder where they're found,
allow us to be able to affect the materials
the way that we need.
Now, if we go to these objects,
let's actually pick on the statue here
and we go ahead and go to where it's found in the scene.
We're going to double click on the material
that we have in place
and you'll see that we have one called MPC here.
The MPCs are nested in this material
but we also have the MPC built right alongside it.
If we double click on the MPC,
you'll see that we have an area here for scalar
to be able to control range
and we have vector if we wanted to control color.
We'll do this in the other video
where we'll actually build both of these out.
So if we go into our scene itself,
let me minimize this for a second
and we go ahead and take a look at this material,
the MPC one.
I'm going to click on the magnifying glass for it
and just double click on that material.
You'll see that we have a global roughness high
and it's driving our multiply here.
And we also have an MPC here for global roughness low
and wetness both punched into a multiply
which actually can work pretty well.
This just allows us to control the range on or off
in a particular if we want to go high or low
with this particular look.
Now I'm using it in the specular.
You don't have to, but you do have to be careful
and I'll show this in the next video
between specular and roughness
because one can turn the other one off.
That's something you just have to be aware of
when working with Unreal.
You'll notice that our global roughness high
is punched into the A channel.
You can also punch that into the B channel
and in here we have a roughness texture set in place.
Now these now, once they're loaded in Sequencer
allow us to be able to control the look and feel
of our objects in our scene.
Well, that's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to go and build these out
and you're going to see them applied in this scene
and see how they work.
Thanks again.